okay new
that's live chair thank you
um before we start actually i am only
working on an ipad
and there's rather a lot of you so if
anybody wants to speak i'd be grateful
if you could type it in
i might not see you thank you
um right uh
damon did you want to come back in at
this point
um yes thank you just to say that i'm
going to record the meeting
um
[Music]
just so members are aware thanks thank
you chair
thank you are there any declarations of
interest
everybody's need new minutes of the last
meeting
right does anybody want to propose the
correct
council row and have we got a seconder
thank you right we'll move on to item
four
uh hackney carriage tariff increase
increase request
which is on page 8 20 and i think that's
over to kevin please
good afternoon chair good afternoon
members um
if everybody recalls it seems quite a
while ago now it seems as though we've
had a lot of water under the bridge in
the last six months i'm not sure what
was
but um the at the last
meeting members approved a tariff
increase for the limited number of
hacking carriages we have
and that um proposal was subject to
going out to statutory consultation
we've now completed the statutory
consultation
that's required by the legislation and
we have received um three
representations
in respect of the con
the proposals just so that you're aware
the statutory advert was placed in the
derbyshire times
and it was displayed at the council
offices in accordance with the
legislation
in addition it was also placed on the
council's website and
a number of um releases were made
via social media to make the general
public aware
that the proposal was ongoing
so we had through representations and
these are contained
item 1.4 within the report
the first one is from a mr kurt jones
who says that i've just seen the
proposed increases to the hackney
carriage tariffs listed in the
derbyshire times
i must admit that i'm surprised to see
such increases
being proposed at the current time
because of the following
excellent diesel costs have fallen by
around 20
in the last 12 months many bus services
in north east irish have been caught in
the last 12 months
or so and many districts and villages
have no public transport after 6 pm
such as winger west for example so more
people need to use taxes to make
everyday journeys such as those working
shifts or
visiting hospitals the cost of taxes may
even deter people from looking for work
because of the cost of travel the
nighttime economy has been decimated by
kobe 19
and any increase in the evening taxi
terrorists will deter
even more people from traveling to their
local community center
club or restaurant this will result in
even more closures and job losses
in conclusion i think in the current
economic climate
it would be unwise to increase tax
affairs
when the true cost of motoring has
actually fallen in the last 12 months
especially this
the succeeding one eighth of a mile
tariff
rising from 20 to 25 p
an increase of approximately 25 percent
the second representation was a from
mr nahim and mohammed who says
looking at these increased tariffs i
think
it wouldn't make any difference as the
hackney drivers will still charge
extortionate fees
to their customers never turn on the
meter
just set a high fixed price especially
on the weekend from chesterfield town
centre
and the customers and the customers to
be reluctant to pay
as they have no other way to get home in
the early hours of the morning
is there anyone who oversees or checks
regularly
on the hackney carriage drivers
overcharging customers
and then the third one was from shaw's
taxes in clay cross
which said regarding the tariff increase
of north establishing
taxes having read your proposal that the
increase
may suggest that your increase comes in
line with that of chesterfield borough
which we had an increase four years ago
as you were aware i operate in both
boroughs
and there is an ongoing conflict in the
prices when a northeast
takes a party out and a borough brings
them back
causing arguments and confusion
excuse me to customers when you explain
the different prices
therefore could the rise be the same
tariff as the borough
which i sent you a tariff sheet some
four years ago
when i first approached you for an
increase due to the fact it had been
over nine years since the last increase
yeah to the right of each of those
comments at 1.4
i've put a response in from officers
um so that members can see what our
thoughts are on those comments that have
been submitted
and if i can draw my members attention
to
1.5 in the report i've provided members
with a tariff comparison bearing in mind
shorts or talking talking about the
chesterfield tariff
um if members would like to look at
tariff one the first one
is our current tariff which has an
initial charge of two pounds
and then 20 pence per eighth of a mile
the proposed is 2 pound 10 and then 25
feet and then if you compare
chesterfields that's the 2 pounds 3
initial charge and then 23 pence per
mile
if you then look at the remainder of the
table that shows you
what the total cost would be
for one mile two mile three miles and so
on
so if members would like to look at that
the proposed tariff for the first mile
in northeast derbyshire
would be three pound 85
as opposed to three pound 91 in
chesterfield
so the target for chesterfield is
actually
six pence more for the first mile what
members will then see
is that anything over one mile
the northeast derbyshire proposed tariff
is actually
higher than the chesterfield tariff
now the reason why we've done that is
because
we're considerably more rural than
chesterfield
a lot of the journeys carried out by
chesterfield hackney carriages
are actually short journeys whereas a
lot of the
journeys carried out by northeast
vehicles
tend to go between the townships and as
a result a lot of the vehicles will
return back to their base empty
um so that's that forms my solution at
this stage
chair um options for members are to
either
adopt the tariff as it was advertised in
statue
reject the tariff completely or to
propose a different tariff
and that's the matter for members today
and obviously kevin will
advise you on that if necessary thank
you very much
thank you kevin does anybody uh wish to
speak
make a comment
now can can i just can i just
uh make a comment i'm counseling
counselor carry on
thank you um i know it's
it's been said earlier about um
fuel uh coming down um
etc but i'm suspecting that
the um acne carriages and indeed all
taxes drivers are spending
more money on cleaning equipment
and i'm not too sure if the covered
rules mean that they have to actually
wipe down handles etc which is going to
bring
an added cost on top of the fuel and the
maintenance of the vehicle
um can anybody actually
um sort of journeys when they pick up
and drop off are they expected to
actually wipe down surfaces which
obviously there's going to cover more
costs
for that
yeah if i can just come in there there
has been
guidance issued by the government which
relates
to recommending that drivers wear faster
face masks in their vehicles
and also increase cleaning of the
vehicle both inside and outside of the
vehicle
so there are significantly more costs
involved for them at the present time
due to kovid
obviously any carriage tariff
increase that members approved
wouldn't just be for the period of kovig
19 it will continue afterwards as well
any other comments
no i can't see anybody um are we happy
for the council kevin's got his handle
oh i say sorry cancer kerry
can i can i ask with very few
heightened carriage licenses in
northeast derbyshire haven't we
the chair i would have to go away and
double check but we've probably
got round about 10 licensed happy
carriages in the district
and we've probably got in the region of
right now on the huntley carriage
licenses
how many of those 10 hackney carriage
licenses
are coal uh can't work with chesterfield
um chair um probably six out of ten
and i'm estimating figures here you have
to appreciate i've not gone away and
done the research on this
but i would suggest six out of ten of
those vehicles work for shores
or are shaw's vehicles and
they have both northeast arbiter and
chesterfield glasses vehicles
so when they get a booking for a job
they would dispatch
either a chesterfield or the north east
derbyshire vehicle to carry out that
work
now is this just is this licensing just
for
me or for heightening and private hire
we cannot regulate fast for private hire
vehicles
so this tariff would only apply
to hackney carriages we're only allowed
under the legislation to set
a maximum tariff for heightening
carriages
so private hires it's up to the operator
to set the rates they want to charge
and they can alter them as they see fit
and they can go to market rent or money
rate
you've answered my questions and i
i'm quite coming around to the opinion
that as we have so few hackney carriage
operators and most of them are
co-terminus
with chesterfield that it would seem
logical
uh to align the hackney carriage rate
with the chesterfield borough
that that's my thoughts at the moment i
don't know what other people
think
in principle i wouldn't have an issue
with that obviously so it's the members
decision
um there will be no reason to go back
out to statutory
yes ultimately the count the committee
can make a decision now
to adjust based on the feedback that
you've received and we can then proceed
to implement those rates
would everybody else be in agreement
with councillor kerry
sorry councillor pickering thank you jay
yes i was just going to say i completely
agree with uh
councillor kerry it's such small numbers
um you know and it's only half a dozen
really that we're
talking about um in terms of any impact
we might as well align the borough and
north east with our with our charges
i think it might be easier for customers
as well all
all around check could have connected
to comments if that's okay please okay
kevin
um the first one is if we are going to
align
our affairs with chesterfield could i
suggest
that we say that it is only the fairs
there are some additional charges around
soiling of vehicles
and i think they vary slightly so if
members are
minded to go with the chesapeake
could i suggest that that is just in
relation to the affairs
not in relation to all the charges if
that's okay
the second point and
it would need considerable consideration
is
bearing in mind how few acne carriages
we actually license in the district the
legislation
does allow for us to not actually set a
tariff
for hackney carriages so effectively
we could decide that we know not going
to set a tariff
and then it would be up to the trade in
a similar way to private higher vehicles
to set their own rates
no sorry i was just agreeing with you
okay cancer pickering thank you chair
um i mean the only comment i'd make on
that is it's my understanding and i
might be wrong so please correct me
we don't actually have any carriage
stands in northeast armstrong
so they'd all be stood in chesterfield
so i don't think really we ought to be
having
unregulated uh fair carriages
stood at the side of regulated ones so
if it's all hours standing in
chesterfield they perhaps ought to be
all under the same
fair rules you know the fair charges
i need to clarify that i'm afraid either
i will or kevin wills
and our vehicles are not allowed to
apply for hire
in chesterfield they can only apply for
hire or stand
within our district they can undertake
pre-booked work from chesterfield
picking up or dropping off in
chesterfield but that has to be
pre-built
but they can't stand for higher in
chesterfield district
thank you for that clarification kevin
thank you
yes thank you uh
it was only one minor one uh kevin asked
for uh
just a slight difference uh with regard
to the hackney carriage license
charges in chesterfield and northeast
derbyshire
most people seem to say that
they thought it was a reasonable idea
for chesterfield and northeast
armageddon carriages
to make set the license be the same
which i agree with
uh but not to go the whole hog
and some of the secondary charges that
chesterfield
uh impose uh not to do that with just
uh north east garbage that's what you
were saying weren't you kevin
you're on mute kevin
i haven't actually gone away and double
checked
what the secondary charges are
progesterone such as soiling a vehicle
so i would recommend that members stick
with the proposal for that from
ourselves
in relation to the secondary charges and
if they want to go with the chesterfield
tariff
one two and three that's what we do
thank you
yeah i was i was i'm happy to go with
that
i took your point on the secondary bits
that would make it more difficult
so i i i'm happy to go with that
kevin yeah i was just going to point out
that when it comes to the secondary
charges i don't believe
that we should be changing those at this
stage because of that on that we would
probably have to go back out to
consultation and as a new range of
charges i'd be reluctant to go down that
road from a legal point of view
so we're all happy with that yes i would
second that
do we have a proposal to someone oh
sorry i thought you did
i'll i'll propose it for our second
counselor carries whatever
well we'll let councillor winley propose
it then
do we have a second i'll second it
heather
all right counselor second it thank you
right item five um policy on cctv
in taxes sorry just before that is that
a member's content with that is um
agreement to the the motion yes
raise your hands yeah
i think members of contention thank you
policy on cctv in taxes
thank you chair it's me taking this one
um
on a previous update some months ago ago
i did
one year that this was coming however
despite having six months
um run into this there were a number of
issues surrounding scrutiny committee
that meant that
the report had to be put together at the
last minute he then went to
councillor dale's portfolio holder for
sign off and as a result of
obviously he's incredibly busy it just
took a little longer than we planned
to get it approved and that's why it was
so late coming out to members and for
that i want to apologize up front that
you've not had it for as long as i would
have liked
um so normally i go through these
in a fairly uh quick fashion
but if there's any issues at all that
members want me to go back and explain
in more detail then just pick me up
at the rather than moment thank you um
some time ago we were tasked with going
away and looking at introducing
mandatory cctv
in taxes that work
began and it was slow progress for a
number of reasons that revolved around
the legal basis for introducing such a
policy
as of july this year
that has changed significantly there's
government guidance
which encourages local authorities to
introduce this measure
it says that you should only uh
refrain from doing so if
there's a compelling local reason
from my point of view from a legal point
of view there's no obvious compelling
reason
there are no serious issues which cctv
would address
but it does hold value as a preventative
measure
therefore there's two issues that are
before members today
the first is whether or not you believe
there's a strong reason not to introduce
cctv in taxes
[Music]
and that has to be done on a local
assessment and then if you agree that it
should be introduced
then there's a draft policy which we can
talk through
uh if you wish um and what i'm seeking
today is approval to go out on a version
that we can consult on and
what would then happen is after
consultation we bring it back to the
licensing committee for final
changes and approval based on the
feedback we receive
and then it would ultimately have to go
to full council
the consultation will be with the
general public as well as the trade
and other organizations and stakeholders
the um
there are some issues i think members
will probably want to just
give some thought to um
the first one is there is a cost
involved
for taxi and five higher proprietors in
introducing these systems
and in order to get the system that
meets
stringent privacy requirements it has to
be quite a complicated system
and that carries a hefty cost probably
in the region of between five and eight
hundred pound per vehicle
now even if the policy is approved
members may want to give some
consideration to
guiding officers on how to deal with
implementing the policy because
as i'm sure we're all aware uh taxes as
much as any other industry are suffering
massively as a result of the coronavirus
pandemic so there are some big questions
about
how we go about implementing it and the
costs involved
i don't believe they are sufficient to
prevent us introducing the policy
but um members may want to take a view
on those uh
issues as well um
the policy itself uh
effectively amends the existing policy
in various places to introduce this
requirement to have cctv and introduces
a number of safeguards
to ensure that uh data protection
privacy and
human rights are protected
and balanced against the the benefits of
having the system
chair that is a very short summary if
there's any particular issues that
members wish me to go into
in more detail then i'm quite happy to
do so
all right does anybody wish to ask kevin
uh anything
yeah councillor windley yeah
and can i ask if there's any way that um
the owners of the taxis who
are putting these cctvs in can
um get any help with the actual cost of
it or is it
just on their own shoulders
as things stand it's just for them to
bear the cost of doing so
there's no national or local schemes as
far as i'm aware to provide financial
support
i don't know if kevin's aware of
anything um
out there some local authorities
have discussed the possibility of
providing
support to the taxi trade
and that would probably be a discussion
for whilst you may want to to give that
some thought
any decisions around that would
obviously have to go through a different
route
thank you counselor reader
uh kevin can i just ask obviously
there'll be sort of big concerns around
the privacy
part of this and obviously who will be
the data controller who
who will be kind of holding those reins
with that
so what is the kind of view with regards
to who is going to be
yes we're putting it on to the drivers
to sort of up
bear that cost so i guess my question
sort of split into two so
who is the data controller then um
regarding it and and who owns this kind
of privacy for it
and then the other part of it is
is it is it sort of going to be sort of
seen that that driver
i know some vehicles will probably use
their own vehicles do you know what i
mean drivers will have their own
vehicles
what will be sort of the policy
sorry if it's in there already but what
will be the policy around
how much is recorded
um in respect to the first question
the council will act as data controller
so we will hold
legal responsibility for the footage
that's gathered by the system
and uh what will happen is there will be
a recording device placed inside each
vehicle
and that will be encrypted
and it will be uh depending on which
system they go with in all likelihood it
will be accessible by officers using
some sort of using a laptop or some
other mobile
device so we can go and physically
download the footage
so it's secure in the vehicle and then
it can only be accessed by our officers
on a
when absolutely necessary so nobody's
accessing the footage for any
uh unacceptable purposes and so
in respect to the second uh question
the actual system that we're looking at
is uh or the criteria
is one that provides for continuous
visual recording
of the interior of the vehicle
but in order to protect privacy and
prevent intrusion
audio recording would only take place
if the driver or passenger pressed
what's effectively an emergency button
to record uh the conversations going on
in in the vehicle
so that would ensure that oh it would
only be intentional
and it should only be exercised in case
where somebody actually has genuine
immediate concerns that they record any
what i'd call confidential uh
information being exchanged in the
vehicle
okay
counselor row
thank you chair sorry kevin did i read
i've read
i understand what he's saying about the
storage methods or not but did i read
this quite an excellent cost to it
um into well externally
there's obviously the cost of installing
the system
internally for us as an authority and we
until we get to implementation we
wouldn't know quite what
what demands there are going to be
there may be some cost involved in
obtaining the
software necessary to download the
footage
um we're still investigating that and it
may
depend we've got set criteria for the
technology
but we aren't specifying particular
manufacturers
so we're going away we'd go away as part
of the implementation to look at
quite what the costs of the authority
may be and then of course
there will be an additional resource
implication because
we may get data protection requests and
third-party requests for footage and
that will be an increased uh
responsibility for licensing officers
and is it would it be i mean we have one
at work here in fact i'm staring at one
now fully enough but would it be
like a cloud-based system then for the
the because we have to keep the
information if somebody makes a
complaint
whether whether it's acceptable or not
it has to be then saved isn't it for a
period of time
so that's like a cloud-based system
we're not proposing to use a cloud-based
system we're proposing to physically
record in the vehicle
on either a 14 or 28 day loop
so it keeps it for 14 or 28 days and
then overwrites it
whilst cloud-based systems are becoming
increasingly popular
from a data security point of view
if it's located in the vehicle and not
being transmitted to and from the cloud
there's less chance of anybody hacking
or intercepting that data
and so once it creates a bit more of a
burden in terms of actually physically
going out and fetching
footage it does keep it more safe and
secure
great thank you that's great thank you
would it become part of the taxi ammo to
mot
so it would check that they were working
etc at the same time
my understanding looking at how other
authorities are doing it
is that the system would be installed by
an approved installer and it would be
certified as having been installed
correctly
so it wouldn't require any in-depth
assessments when it comes in for its
vehicle
test uh mechanics at the depot would
simply have to check that it's installed
check that there's a certificate of
installation and then just conduct a
very brief test to make sure it's
actually functioning
so it wouldn't be it wouldn't change
they wouldn't add to the test
significantly
that's the thickering
thank you chair and my question really
is about
um access to using it what the driver
have any control over whether the system
was on or off
or does it automatically come on when
the car is in use
and i'm just thinking of those operators
that use their
family car for the business as well so
when it's been using the private
capacity
would it be recording that user's family
that's a very good point and it's one
we've taken into consideration
the system is usually activated
physically
by use of a switch on the unit in the
boot so
what we would expect is and what we
would impose on drivers
in their license conditions is that when
they're about to start working
they activate the system and it records
visually continuously whilst they're on
shift
once they're finished they can switch it
off and they can leave it off when using
the vehicle for personal use
thank you thank you for that
is there anybody else wishing to speak
uh councillor hutchinson
thank you for that and good afternoon
everybody as you know this is my first
time with you today um so just to bring
me up to date
the the you've i think you've answered a
question about who's operating this
system
but the intention is to protect who the
driver
and the customer yeah
both effectively and we've
when you look at um other authorities
some have brought in in response to
specific problems
um which we don't have in this district
it's but it's
it doesn't it doesn't take away the
benefit of the system as a preventative
measure
so if you look at for example rotherham
their problems are well documented
they've introduced theirs primarily to
protect the safety of occupants of the
vehicle
if you look at somewhere like
southampton who have also introduced
with difficulty but have introduced
something similar
a lot to their justification was around
problems that drivers were experiencing
um and it was that you know it holds
equal value for protecting drivers
okay thank you for that but my initial
thoughts are
that if what you you said kevin about
turning this switch on
the boot if if if
somebody was wanting to transport
something
um then that this is not really going to
cover that is it because
if you turn it on and off uh i would
guess a camera will be housed on the
dashboard
so the transporting if you were going to
transport something we'll say illegally
it's not going to cover that is it
that's correct the the i suppose what
you'd call the
the gap in this system or the loophole
is that if you are if you're up to no
good
you won't turn the system on so if
you're going to use your car to
transport drugs
or people that you shouldn't be
then you're going to run it without the
cctv
functioning what i would say is that if
a vehicle is being observed if the
police to investigating or licensing
officers
happen to spot the vehicle and
it appears to be in use then
if they are officially on the books and
working
and haven't switched it on then they'll
be in breach of their license conditions
so it has some investigatory merit
it has some merit on the basis that well
if they've switched the camera off
and they appear to be carrying someone
or something that in the vehicle then
it's going to set off red flags but
you're correct we won't actually have
any footage of that
thank you very much excuse my naivety
i'm just trying to get into
the feel of the thing thank you for that
in roland okay if i can just add
to what kevin said one of the issues
licensing authorities have at the moment
is
um previous rulings by the information
commissioner
so they have looked at
um cctv systems that have been put in
vehicles
by other authorities so for instance the
voice recording element of it
um southampton originally said they
wanted
video and voice recording whenever the
vehicle was in use
and the information commissioner said
that that was a breach
of privacy hence the reason that
systems now have to switch it so that
you
can turn the audio on if you need to
turn it off
and they've taken a similar stance in
relation to the video element
when the vehicle is being used for
private use hence the reason why
there will be a switch in the boot it's
not ideal
but unfortunately we've got privacy on
one hand
and we've got safety on the other and
it's trying to marry them all the best
that we can
councillor windley um yeah i think
with semi going around what was in my
mind and that was
if you have say um a private
hire um that
has got a fair maybe an airport or
wherever and is there any way
that they have to let anyone else
know that they are actually doing this
fair or is it just purely in their own
books
just if that makes sense it's the case
of you know
um you get i'll liken it to the care
agencies
some of them have to phone in or
the the agencies know where they are
but in a private someone that's
operating a private
um taxi they will just
get in and go so is there any way of
monitoring
when they actually working do they have
to notify anybody
that or keep logs of when they should be
working
the short answer to that question is
the only records that are required to be
kept
although or by the operator who takes
the booking
for that journey um they don't they're
not required to notify anyone beyond
that
and those records those booking records
would
we expect them to be retained and we
can go and check them if we have cause
to do so
but we wouldn't expect an operator to to
provide us with their records
uh as a matter of course
right so in that case then the
cctv wouldn't always be
um as effective as what
we might hoped if it's not if they don't
bother to switch it on
for any reason um
correct if they fail to switch it on we
lose the benefits of cctv footage
yeah what i would say is that if
somebody fails to switch it on
they will be placing their license at
risk because it would be considered a
serious breach of their license
conditions to actually be carrying fares
without the cctv being operational so
um the vast majority of responsible
vehicle proprietors and drivers we would
expect would
would use the system properly and
if we had to we could go out and we
could compare the booking records to a
vehicle's usage
and if we became apparent they hadn't
been switching the
recording equipment on then they'd end
up back before
a licensing subcommittee if they were
persistently
and you'd be looking at whether or not
they should have a licence at all
thank you anybody else
no one's indicating chat i don't think
so
so where do we go from here then kevin i
was check if i could ask the first
question
from the conversations that have been
going on i suspect i know the answer to
this one
but perhaps if anybody uh wants to
uh comment do does anybody have uh what
they consider to be a compelling
local reason why we shouldn't introduce
this policy
i thought i think i think generally
everyone's ease that
whilst there are problems with the the
system and problems with
uh the balance of privacy and everything
uh
in general there's enough merit in the
system that we ought to make this policy
forward
um so if that's the case my second
so if that's the case can i'd suggest
that
one of the members wants to move
that you're happy for the uh
you're happy that there is no compelling
local reason then we can proceed to the
second question
yeah i'm happy to do that
i'll second that thank you
thank you jeff um assuming everybody's
in favor of that then
the thank you and
the second question for yourselves is
there is a draft policy
that's um attached to the report
uh which incorporates everything that we
we've been talking about are you happy
for us to go out and consult on that
policy as drafted
any comments anybody cancer pickering
i would just indicate in my
right so so i just chad i just need
somebody to move and
and second that we go out to
consultation
i'll move it somebody wants a second yes
counselor reader yeah cancer reader
thank you
are we all going to vote on that that's
fine with everybody
councillor huckabee you're voting yes
believe so i believe so yes
thank you chair uh that's it for me
thank you i've got enough to go away and
get working on
thank you very much thank you right well
um i've noticed any matters of urgency
so i think that's the meeting close
thank you
thanks everybody for coming good job
thank you
you